tension between a clay and Christian
erupts over Nicole new dates over when
we come back to Paradise I'm a
straightforward guy man I literally just
walked in here
Blake drama took a back seat during
Tuesday night's episode of bachelor in
paradise as Nicole's love square took
center stage paradise to waste no time
I'm super confident have I had a great
time with her and my date we finish off
Monday night Christian who was sent home
on night one of Beca kufran season of
The Bachelorette showed up on the beach
with a date card and his sights were set
on Nicole do you want to stay here and
talk to clay are you actually weren't
pardon me you haven't you had a date
segments listen I told you I have a
connection with play exciting White
House everybody
yeah so we need brunette beauty you was
spending a lot of time with clay before
Christians arrivals but feels he may be
too passive for her
he already has that like confidence in
him that I like
[Music]
Papi's getting me high Hey
and now with Christian on the beach it
seems Nicole is open to exploring her
options I thought I do what I want to
but maybe I don't but things turned
explosive ahead of the rose ceremony as
clay tried to interrupt the pair while
sharing a champagne and strawberries
very romantic set up honestly I really
like and yada and everything but I would
like to steal a call for a moment and I
will give you an opportunity to talk to
her later you know but I'll be honest
with you off I feel like that was me
yesterday you're not gonna give me
opportunity you were with her all day of
course well just fill her for one moment
this dude I'll bring her back you are
not gonna take her I'm not gonna to take
her there's so many things I gotta find
you talk to you real quick I have
something I want to tell you got a
strawberry bro I'm good you get you can
you can have those strawberries although
clay played it off like a gentleman
Jordan came to clays defense pausing
this epic moment Christian I'm really
sorry plays a good friend of mine okay
we'll have to stay tuned to next
Monday's episode to see whether those
white pants got dirty but at least we
got a little teaser next week on
bachelor in paradise things get a little
physical yeah
things either look we we want drama we
love story we like the craziness but
there's a line and anything that gets
physical is the line yeah we can't stand
for it we can't have it yeah things
boiled over one night and got out of
control
it looks a little scary I mean you got
serious it you got serious but we are
really this is why I'm very proud of
what we do is producers we have security
there on the beach and it's not really
for this reason they're not bouncers
because it's more for the security of
everybody while we're in Mexico and
protecting everybody but they also
turned into bouncers that night me
quickly got this subdued and taken care
of but yeah I got really heated really
quick that happens these a bunch of
type-a personalities trying to fall for
the same woman and people and it's you
know you don't see it a lot with women
guys really okay not a testosterone
[Music]